when I was a freshman in college I made
a ton of money in what I can only
describe as the weirdest of
circumstances and this is that story
hello again before we dive in I should
emphasize how weird this story is it
doesn't make any sense but it's
completely true I'm also gonna be vague
about names locations specifics because
you'll see here we go so I was 19 a
freshman in college
aka broke so one day I'm just hanging
out with some friends and someone
mentions that there's I don't know what
else to call it but an event happening
where students could make money oh cool
what do we have to do tutor some kids
hand out some flyers what are we talking
here no he says there's this bar you
bring your ID with you show it to these
people and they give you $20 just making
sure I understand this I show people my
license and I get $20 and that's it red
flag right from the start here what is
happening why would I get money for just
showing someone my ID of course looking
back now it sounds incredibly sketchy
but then let's do this why wouldn't we
what's the worst that could happen we
don't get $20 may as well check this out
so the day arrives when this event is
happening and a group of us go to this
bar write down your name and phone
number and get in line someone says easy
paperwork done we're waiting in line we
reach the front there's two men behind
the bar ID the one guy asks 20 bucks
here we come I hand my license over I
can smell the cash one sec he says and
walks away with my ID whoa no no no
excuse me what is going on this was
supposed to be a clean exchange Oh God I
knew this was a bad idea is my identity
stolen I knew this was too good to be
here
he says and hands me back my license
with a $20 bill hmm
okay as for everyone else they got $20 -
so this thing that sounded completely
impossible is in fact very real I know
what you're thinking cool story that's a
ton of money this story sucks and to
that I say chill because we're just
getting started a few days go by and I
get a voicemail there was something like
gratulations you've been selected for
the next round please bring your ID to
the same address what the hell is going
on only one other friend of mine got
this voicemail they were narrowing
people down was I supposed to be excited
or terrified
I weighed my options my ID was probably
being used to take out loans for drug
mansions overseas $20 I'm now a part of
the mafia and currently being watched by
FBI $20 let's do this so the day comes
again I go to the bar fill out my name
number again shorter line this time
apparently these IDs were the best of
the best I get up to the bar and my ID /
he walks away again this is probably
where my good luck runs out he'll come
back and say I have to apply for some
fake credit card or something it's a
shame because I was really starting tea
hands me my ID and $100 at this point I
am really struggling to not laugh not
only did I get money I got five times
the amount of money is this my job now
is this how I make a living folks step
right up and take a look at what some
call the finest ID in these here United
States my friends are waiting outside
the bar they're just as confused as I am
the money is really starting to pile up
here what if I told you this story is
about to get 10 times weirder maybe a
week goes by I get another mysterious
voicemail
congratulations you've been selected as
the final person please meet us on
Saturday morning at this intersection
blah blah blah blah this time it wasn't
even an address it was just an area
downtown but in the morning rope I had a
decision to make do I continue showing
up in strange places at the promise of
money with no idea what's waiting for me
where do I just quit while I'm ahead as
you're watching this you're probably
like Bridget come on there's no way
you're dumb enough to see this through
you probably came to your senses like a
sane human let's do this I know I know
it's bad okay but I went I wanted to see
what life had in store for me I didn't
go alone though I brought a friend we
head to this corner downtown we're
standing there on the sidewalk what are
we supposed to be looking for suddenly a
van door just slides open yeah a van
this is it this is how I die there's a
group of at least five people in this
van a man and a woman get out goodbye
cruel world all right so here's what's
gonna happen
the woman hands me an envelope there's
seven thousand dollars cash in here and
here's a list I'm gonna fasten I'm gonna
fasten now and this is my hit list the
games are an order of priority seats
together no partial viewing a glance
around as she's talking oh we're outside
of the stadium wait wait wait am i
buying tickets to a sporting event if
you're thinking of leaving this video
don't because this story gets crazier
the lady explains to me that I'm about
to have the chance to buy tickets that
the general public doesn't have access
to yet it was up to me to get as many of
the games on this list as possible
okay okay a little confusing with all of
the requests that they had but this
isn't nearly as scary one more thing
woman says under no circumstances do you
tell anyone where you got this money or
who we are wait what who why
what's your confidence booster at least
my friend can come with me we start to
walk towards the stadium no he stays
here
of course leaving my friend on the
corner all by myself here goes nothing
there was a small group of rich looking
businessmen gathered outside the stadium
someone from inside the stadium pokes
their head out of the door we're ready
for you follow me this way I'm assuming
that includes me we walk into the
stadium down this hole and the guy
pushes on what looks like a wall it's a
door that leads into this dimly lit
conference room there is no one under 35
years old stuff for me there are no
women in this room except for me
everyone is in a suit except for me the
same person who led us into the stadium
explains how will be picking games and
who gets what tickets
I stuck exactly to what the people in
the van had told me eventually
we were done the stadium person speaks
up again I don't imagine this is the
case but no one is paying with cash
correct my stomach does a backflip all
the businessmen are obviously shaking
their heads now [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I
have to raise my hand I literally have
an envelope of 7,000 dollars yes I have
cashed I am paying with cash everyone
was clearly aware of the small blonde
girl from the start but now everyone's
eyes are on me it felt like I was in a
movie when someone goes she doesn't even
go here but that didn't happen okay you
can swing around to the front of the
stadium and pick your tickets up there
we all go out front everything seems
normal I walked to the ticket window
slide my list of games through the slot
the woman behind the glass looks me up
and down she turns around and puts all
of the tickets I need into an envelope
she slides it back through the slot
towards me I come we reach for them but
her hand is still on the tickets all
sound is gone I feel like I'm gonna
throw up with the deepest eye contact
I've ever felt she looks at me and asked
who sent to you I stare back at her
I say nothing with her other hand the
woman turns around to pick up a phone I
don't know who she wants to call but I
don't want to stick around to find out
I slam the cash on the counter I grab
the tickets and I run I run as fast as I
can
thinking back I didn't hear anything no
yelling no sirens after all I didn't pay
for the tickets
not with my money but I paid for them
the air stings my lungs does that make
it back to the band out of sight of the
stadium
my friend is still there unharmed nobody
has any idea what I just went through
I practically throw the tickets into the
van they quick flip through the envelope
checking the tickets against their list
the van people look at me they hand me
an envelope this is for you oh yeah I'm
getting paid for this with a heavy thud
the door slide shut and the band drives
out that would ultimately be the last
time I saw or even heard from these
people my friend and I opened the
envelope it had $500 in it to a college
student I practically struck the lottery
keep in mind that this was $500 for
maybe an hour of my time did I think
someone was gonna steal my kidney is
kinda was this whole experience worth it
not really
oh and guess what that night we all went
out to celebrate my accomplishments and
guess who loses their wallet really
great all that had been for nothing
but in the end I did come away with a
really great story
[Music]
hey unsub is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part